we've seen a number of high-profile
criminal cases lately and sometimes
something goes wrong and a mistrial is
declared and unfortunately
people often misunderstand what a
mistrial is now
people know that that means that the
trial has to end
but people think that that means that
the defendant just goes off scot-free
that's not true
a mistrial would be more accurately
described as a mulligan if a mistrial is
declared then the prosecutor can just
simply bring the charges again sometimes
they do sometimes they don't
this happens if there is an error that
is so prejudicial that it cannot be
overcome through
instructions or sometimes when the jury
is deliberating for so long but they
can't come to a decision
they hang and therefore a mistrial is
declared so that the prosecutor can
start the trial again with a new jury
pool so mistrial doesn't mean the
defendant goes free it just means the
prosecutor can bring the charges again
so now you know next time i see you in
court